okay good morning everyone it is 10 a.m.
time for the
Tuesday February 13th meeting of the
science technology and energy committee
which will begin as is our custom with
all of us rising and joining
representative Harrington as he leads us
Allegiance Al to the flag the United
States of America to The Republic which
stands one
nation
all thank you and good morning to
everyone thank you for your attention
this morning we have a full committee
work session that we will conduct from
now
until we have
exhausted the matters before us the
discussion matter is before us but
before we start that work session we
have some announcements that we want to
discuss with the
committee after we finish the work
session by the way there will be a
republican caucus in this room and then
we'll have a lunch break and then we'll
be back here at 1:00 for an executive
session so last week we had uh some
discussion about the proper way
to make a
motion on a bill that we want to amend
and then how to move the amendment and
how to vote on the
amendment and I suggested at the time
that we didn't have to vote on the
amendment and some people questioned
that so I went to the clerk and had an
extensive conversation with
him and this has a subject that had come
up several times before in fact the
clerk had had uh a discussion about it
in a chairs and vice chairs meeting
and at that
meeting he did state that you do not
have to have a roll call on an amendment
you can vote on an amendment with a show
of
hands and there was a bunch of back and
forth discussion after he made that
statement
and it got confusing after a
while
and I came away from the discussion
thinking that we did not have to vote on
an amendment based on the different
threads that emerged during that
discussion so the clerk clarified for me
last week that we do have to vote on an
amendment it can be a roll call Vote or
it can be a show of hands I think you
can even do a v Voice vote if you want
but you do have to vote on the amendment
so going forward we will always vote on
an amend Amendment separately and then
vote on the motion of ought to pass as
amended Vice chair
Thomas yes thank you Mr chair I think
and and to that end regardless of how
it's done I believe the clerk still has
to check off each box for each member as
how they voted so um however we do it I
believe it it needs to be recorded on on
well
Mr clerk uh do you concur with that
observation that is consistent with the
training that I originally had uh two
years
ago so if it was a vote by a show of
hands people would have to hold their
hand up long enough for you to actually
go through and check off each member's
vote
Yes okay so if we do do a voice not a
voice but a show of hands
vote I will try to remind everybody to
keep your hand raised until the clerk
indicates that he has recorded your vote
appears yes as long as we see
everybody's hand we we'll have to ask
everybody to raise their hand at that
point so are there any additional
representative parshall thank you chair
I think this a a softball question but
what is the status of this particular
bill right now are we going to bring the
bill back to executive committee for a
vote or is it uh are that's looking
towards the future so the clerk said
that the bills that we exec last week
are good to go even though we didn't do
the process correctly they're still good
to go because there was nothing terribly
controversial about about any of the
bills so we don't have to redo the ones
we already did we just have to do it
correctly going
forward okay now representative Bernardi
has been working to put together a trip
to ISO New England and he would like to
talk to you about
that yes thank you Mr chair uh I think
most folks saw my email and I have uh
confirmation from several people that
they are interested in going and
interested in in the van so um let me
just indicate who has said
yes uh so representative Corman said yes
but may not take the van Representatives
Noel PL bney McGee Kaplan uh Wendy
Thomas Doug Thomas and Janine nder as
well as myself of all said yes is there
anybody else
who
Okay
and you're likely
likely okay thank
you um the other subject that I uh put
in the email that I wanted some feedback
on uh is what were there any specific
topic areas or subject areas that you
wanted uh ISO New England to be ready to
respond to to um
uh answer a question that you're going
to put forward to them that so that
they're they're ready for that or um uh
areas that you want covered as part of a
discussion
representative
Corman thank you uh first of all it's um
I'm probably not going to be taking the
van so if it's uh a a question of do we
need a larger van because I'm going to
be there probably I won't be in in the
van driving separately uh the one thing
I'd really be curious to see it's not so
much um the hardware but i' I'd be
auction representative Thomas
thank you um I'm interested in hearing
about any nuclear oversight that they
may be doing thank
you representative lii uh thank you um
depending on conditions with the van it
may be better for me to go separately
because I'm already South and U it might
be you know if the van's going to be
packed then it' be easier if I do go
separately representative McGee concurs
with that um um Vice chair Thomas uh yes
thank you uh at the risk of opening up a
can of worms um in in the in the past if
you have specific questions uh of iso
New England in the past they have asked
us to forward those questions to them as
soon as possible so that they can
address them either once they're there
or experience shows that sometimes it
takes them a lot longer to respond to
those questions but in either case if
you have a specific question I would
suggest maybe you funnel it to
representative Bernardi and maybe we can
get with um their contact point and for
and saying here's things that we're
interested in and just see what they say
that's that would that would be that
would be the best way to handle it prior
to waiting you know before just waiting
until we got there so that might be
helpful so just to recap on those who
may not take the van Representatives
Corman McGee licki and Wendy
Thomas and you're going down Route three
right we're going to Holy Oak mass
there well if you're going to do that
okay maybe you could uh circulate as
soon as you find out where where the van
is going yeah let people know so that
people could decide yes or no on the van
yep all
right and what day is this trip again 12
March 12 March isn't that town meeting
day yes it
is that's going to be a problem for
me
yeah yeah okay
well it is what it is right so the
time
so given the the length of that trip I'd
say it's going to be a pretty early
morning start like 8 a.m. and probably
not returning to the L till 5:00 a.m. or
5:00
p.m. might not be able to vote right
well that's true that's why I I
well do you want to consider
um I I can do that I can I can check see
whether another date's possible okay has
it
always has it already been noticed in
the calendar no it has not been noticed
in the calendar I just I just asked that
it be noticed this morning so it hasn't
happened
yet all
right okay so the basic issue here is
that this trip is being
planned the planning is not maybe
complete yet so we will continue to work
on that just uh pay attention to rep
representative Bernard's emails if you
trip
okay uh Vice chair Thomas do you have
any other information about any upcoming
presentations or anything uh only that
we're working uh for presentations or I
should say representative Berard will be
working with for presentations with
Department of energy and depart and
Department of Environmental Services
those the only two things that we
currently are are looking at right now I
first
okay all
right anything else on this
subject all right let's get to work then
on our full committee work session we're
going to talk about three bills this
morning House Bill 1644 FN requiring the
department of energy to initiate an
investigation of the benefits and key
considerations regarding support for
clean or non-carbon emitting power
generation HB 1465 relative to studies
of nuclear energy Technologies and hb1
1431 relative to utility requirements
for
integrated distribution planning
Mr chairman yes over here representative
Ms could I could I ask that we um that
we put HB 1465 to the end of the list
because uh there's an amendment that
should be available within the next half
hour 45
minutes sure thank you not a
problem but we will start with HB 1644
FN and I am passing out right at this
2024-the
that
the the original version of the bill was
to convert our renewable portfolio
standard into a zero emission portfolio
standard and I actually had the language
RPS and then I abandoned that draft
because it couldn't make it work
financially and went with the draft that
was subsequently filed as the bill as
introduced since that time the
Connecticut legislature has added RPS to
its I mean added nuclear to its RPS
using using language that's virtually
identical to what I've uh proposed in
this amendment
to hb1 1644 so this amendment would
replace the entire
Bill and change the name of the
bill so
that after September 1st of 2024 any
newly
built
nuclear power generating facility that
commenced operation would be eligible
Rex now what this bill does is it hangs
out a sign that says New Hampshire is
open for business when it comes to
nuclear energy obviously there are no
nuclear power
plants currently being proposed or built
in New Hampshire so this would not
affect the
RPS at any point in the foreseeable
future but what it would do is it would
send a signal that should somebody
decide that maybe New Hampshire is a
good place to build a nuclear
facility that the state is open to
supporting
it so that's why I'm proposing this
amendment it's a fairly simple Amendment
as you can see and I'm interested in
your reactions to it
representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman um I think
it's well-intentioned
um my
concern off just you know off the cuff
in reviewing it when we received it
yesterday was that um this hasn't
been uh an addition
to a class which is uh new renewable
right class one um it hasn't been
studied in in terms of economic impact
to your point there wouldn't be an
immediate inter impact but you would
also be setting up um multiple classes
of nuclear right so there would be an
advantage to any new nuclear plants and
you know the existing nuclear plant
would be playing on a different playing
field uh as would all the other
renewable Generations so I think it's
something that really has to be studied
before we put it into law um and say
that we can pronounce a solution based
on on what another state has arrived at
without us really understanding the
impact um economically basically on our
energy sources
discussion Vice chair Thomas thank you
Mr chair uh I I like the amendment I I
think it does exactly what the chair uh
says it's supposed to do do um true if
and when um someone ever became
interested in coming to New Hampshire I
think at that time we could easily um
submit something else that could say uh
we we need to maybe study something uh
that would um to make sure that we've
had all the te's cross eyes dotted but I
think to get us off the board right now
I think this is a good Amendment if we
want to come back next year with
something to add to it we perhaps could
further
discussion representative Corman thank
you Mr
chairman um I'm I'm a little
uncomfortable with with uh placing
nuclear power as a renewable source um I
don't view it really as renewable it
requires a fuel that is is mined and
processed it I I don't see it as
renewable um I also have a slight
concern about the amount of power that
nuclear can produce swamping some of the
things that we do consider renewable in
that class um and I'm not against
nuclear but I I I I do have a a a small
concern about that um I recognize that
most likely any nuclear facility that uh
that arises in New Hampshire will
probably be much smaller scale than what
we have now uh so I'm I I don't know how
well-founded that concern is but I
wonder if it might make sense to to try
to put some cap on the size of a nuclear
facility uh that that would actually get
the
reck so you might be suggesting that
small nuclear or small modular
reactors uh might be appropriate but a
large reactor might not that that's
right and and I don't really think we're
going to see any new large reactors but
I don't
know correct representative licki H
thank you Mr chairman um there is an
issue with small nuclear plants of uh
essentially uh uh scale basically
there's a lot of overhead that you're
going to need you're going to need a
whole different kind of security and so
forth on a nuclear plant than you would
on a uh fossil fuel plant or many other
things and so you know there may be a a
real issue if uh you know if for
instance the you know if you had a 100
megawatt nuclear plant it wouldn't be
worth building because of those uh
overhead
issues representative
rols thank you Mr chairman um I just
wanted to add um my I have a
similar concern as my colleague um
representative Corman with defining
nuclear energy as
renewable um I don't agree that it's
renewable um so however I'm not
anti-nuclear I
um you know I'm I'm open and looking
looking forward to the emergence of uh
small
nuclear reactor technology uh as a
potential answer to the climate problem
um but I would
be I'm essentially supportive of of your
effort here um if if perhaps we made it
a separate
uh somehow I know it's called the
renewable portfolio standard but um some
way distinguishing it um I'm opposed to
applying the label renewable to nuclear
representative
Kennedy uh thank you Mr chairman uh I
just had uh maybe two comments one one
is you know when we talk about renewable
um we have to keep in mind that solar
panels and wind turbines do not last
forever they break down they turn into
junk you know after about 25 or 30 years
and they have to be scrapped and new
ones have to be built the second thing
is um the fuel requirements for nuclear
reactors is extremely low it almost
doesn't add any cost to the electricity
it's a capital cost and and the
workforce that maintain the plant you
know that's where most of the costs come
from uh and the the second comment I had
is since we started to talk about small
modular reactors um I thought I'd
promote my favorite right now um I I was
always a fan of General Electrics
economics simplified Boiling Water
Reactor I thought that was maybe the
best design in the world um it's never
been built but recently General Electric
um decided to get on the SMR bandwagon
and they have a scaled down version of
The Boiling Water Reactor it's the B RW
no boiling pwx
300 so it's a 300 megawatt electric
output
reactor um you know and a side thing we
talked about bow a little bit you know
you know I don't know how we would make
the politics and Economics work but if
you wanted to drop in as that Bill said
a clean reliable source of electricity
you know that wouldn't be a bad thing
and the last comment I would make is
that uh right now General Electric has a
contract to build I think two of these
at Darlington um another aside I used to
swim at the Darlington Beach in the
coolant water
basically um but anyway so this is this
has gotten past the point of you know
unicorns and and whatnot so you know
they're going to build one and
Saskatchewan is also you know in kind of
late discussions on uh you know building
one of these reactors so those are just
two comments uh relative to what we're
talking
about thank you Vice chair Thomas thank
you Mr chair
um I understand what some of our
concerns are here with this amendment
and perhaps there might be room to make
an adjustment um perhaps um before we
exec this bill but I would appeal to the
committee members that we need to start
telling people through our actions that
clean energy nuclear is going to be very
important in in the future as we uh
gravitate to more of the Renewables
whatever class we want to call it in and
I think this amendment would show people
they will begin to see that we
are gravitating towards uh at least
entertaining the idea of of having
nuclear back in the state at some time
in the future if it ever comes but more
importantly it will tell industries that
at least we're open as the chair has
said I think this bill this this
amendment I think would be key to
putting that forward into the future so
however way we can maybe arrange this so
that we can get this through committee I
think would be very important for a
message and further work I'm sure I'm
positive would be done at at the Senate
level so um I believe this amendment is
very important if we can do some tweaks
with it to get it through here that's
fine but I um uh but I think it's
important that we get this through in
some
manner representative
Harrington um yeah uh first of all I
think we shouldn't get too excited one
way or the other about this bill because
no one's going to be building a nuclear
plant New Hampshire in at least 10 years
if even then as as I've said before uh
we're not a vertically integrated State
and and most plans looking at that are
vertically integrated states where the
rate payers would take some of the risk
of building a nuclear plant we also have
a history of anti-nuclear activism in
this in this state so uh when I hear the
head of nuclear at Duke Energy say
they're going to wait 5 to 10 years
because they don't want to be first and
they have a huge Fleet of nuclear plants
with nuclear expertise and in vertically
integrated State and in a state that's
states that have said they like nuclear
power I just don't see it happening here
so let's not get too excited about if we
were to do it to put it out there to say
yeah we're we're interested in nuclear
if you want to think about it it does no
harm and I wouldn't be concerned about
it being mixed up with renewable and
non-renewable because effectively it's
not going to do anything and if 10 years
or 15 years from now something had to be
adjusted we could adjust it then but I
think basically now it's just a sign
saying hey we're interested in nuclear
other states have been doing certain
things I think it was Illinois uh passed
a bill that said they got rid of the
prohibition on nuclear new nuclear power
plants and of course Connecticut doing
this and there's been a few other states
doing the same thing so I I just I I
wouldn't get too hung up on it but uh it
doesn't do any harm representative
parial thank you chair uh in response to
earlier comments about uh the non-
renewability of solar and wind what
we're talking about is not the energy
there we're talking about the devices
that we use to collect those that energy
and for that matter nuclear has has an
even more severe problem and that we
really have not totally solved what
we're doing with the waste so that's one
of my concerns to characterize this as
being you know solar doesn't work
because panels we out nuclear doesn't
work because plants were out uh also I'm
thinking I I I also wholeheartly agree
with uh representative
Herrington um and that this is not
something on the horizon and I think
that we have lots of time to get our
sign hung out for New Hampshire if we
see this is the direction we're going
and lastly I know there are several
concerns about lithium Mining and the
conditions that upon which lithium is
mined and I'm thinking that Cobalt
mining which has been going a lot longer
is not that much better it uses the same
comes from the same parts of the of
Planet such as the Congo and uh it uses
the same labor force which is
questionable there that's the issues
that I have have right now thank you
representative
bernardy thank you Mr chair uh just a
comment on that on the renewability
concept or and the of fuel uh for power
plants um nuclear
plants one of the advantages of uh the
smallscale fast flux reactors is they
can use a reprocessed fuel from one of
the large thermal reactors as potential
fuel source so the concern of of uh what
do we do with the long-term waste of a
large thermal plant can be remediated by
using that as the fuel source in a fast
flux
reactor uh that although not a renewable
resource representative Kaplan
thank you Mr chair um I I agree with a
lot of what's been said here I think
nuclear has potential and and we should
not uh shun it you know instinctively
because of our fears um of uh the you
know past technologies that are being
improved um however I I do agree with
representative Harrington and
representative parall that you know we
are in no hurry and that why are we
intent on sending a signal which at best
is problematic because of of the
possible distortions in in the to the to
the renewable energy portfolio renewable
portfolio standard program I I think
that those possible distortions are
fairly obvious given the different uh
sorts of Technology involved as
representative Corman pointed out uh so
why would we send a a flawed signal like
that um when there's no
hurry well in response to you
representative Kaplan and I appreciate
the those comments I would say I would
argue that there we are in a hurry if
it's going to take 10 or more years to
get one of these plants built we have to
send a signal that it's time to start
working on that
now and we have a serious reliability
problem that we're facing particularly
in the New England region it's it's a
Countrywide problem but it's even more
acute here than it is anywhere else and
I
think time is is short to find a
solution to keeping our lights on going
forward and if we can indicate that
we're as a state open and encouraging of
the development of nuclear power I think
we need to send that message and send it
sooner rather than later who's
next representative Thomas thank you Mr
chair um I have two points one is on the
current uh discussion that's going on
where you said that this sends a message
quote New Hampshire is open for business
um that to me ring rings all kinds of
bells I mean so we're not we haven't
studied this we haven't set up any kind
of guard rails and we're saying come and
build your nuclear plants in New
Hampshire I think that that's really
problematic um number two is that this
bill has a fiscal note attached to it so
does does this amendment alter that
fiscal note in any way yes it eliminates
it invalidates it I should say thank you
representative
muns thank you Mr chair um and um just
to acknowledge what you had said when
you introduced the amendment I did go on
the um state of Connecticut's website
and um you know that that that act did
was passed and uh it was nuclear was
added to the class one renewable
standard as of October 1st of
2023 um but to um follow up on
representative Corman and reel's point
um the one thing that I did notice is
that in Connecticut the class one um
percentage Target um after 2030 is
40% compared to New Hampshire's 15% um
um and so I'm I'm wondering whether you
know if we were to pass this whether
that we should also adjust the the
renewable portfolio standards um for
class one to reflect the fact that
you're you we would be introducing this
new technology that could end up
producing a a significant amount of
power a legitimate
concern and one of the reasons why we
referred for interim study a bill that
we heard earlier this year filed by
representative Harrington to consider
the future of the RPS right now the way
the statute is written after
2025 there's no projection of what the
future of the RPS might look like and
that is something that we need to
consider going
forward but I don't think we should wait
to indicate to the world that we think
nuclear is important representative
liwicki thank you Mr chairman uh we're
all over the map here and I figure this
might be an appropriate Point time to go
further a field but one of the
things uh one of the issues is uh
thorium basically in my mind thorium
they say it's radioactive but in reality
I think it's just fishable and there's
effectively an infinite amount of that
and the daa product is I believe an
isotope inner isotope of lead rather
than U being radioactive itself so you
on uh Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr
chair uh can I have can I ask the the
department of energy a
question sure if the department is
willing to answer it's a short
question
welcome thank you Mr chairman Griffin
robers uh Department of energy you know
who I am sorry uh in in in um reference
to the uh the concern posed by uh uh
representative Thomas earlier if this
bill were to pass this year could there
be a nuclear plant built in the next
year or the year after or even within
three years just by coming in here and
starting it sure thank you for the
question uh I'd say that's a
hypothetical I guess I'm not sure but
developing nuclear resources certainly
does take time um so I'm not aware of
any specific plans to site any new
nuclear resources in the state the next
year or two or three and and follow and
so therefore through licensing processes
and and and and and so forth there would
be uh quite a bit of a time lag there
where during that time period uh certain
things could could be studied before
they even even thought about starting
here would would that be your assessment
you representative McGee do you have a
question for
no anybody have a question for Mr robers
representative
Kaplan yeah I mean thank you Mr robers
for uh taking my
question what do you have can you
foresee any potential impacts of adding
new nuclear technology to the renewable
portfolio standard on the other
renewable energy uh sources getting
renewable energy credits sure um you
know obviously I you know the a lot of
these questions are hypotheticals I
can't predict what would happen but you
know um nuclear resources do produce
quite a bit of generation obviously
depending on the size of anything that's
produced in the future um you know there
is the potential um there for new
resources coming in to crowd without
other resources within class
one any other questions for Mr
Roberge representative partiall I'm
getting drawn in s go ahead thanks I
could say how how about those Chiefs but
uh I won't go there
um how will this how do you foresee this
affecting our current market uh with our
current use of uh the seabook basically
will this have any uh positive or NE
negative impact on the maintenance of
that plant sure and thank you for the
question so based on the language that
you know I'm I'm really just seeing um
you know this is this would allow new
nuclear power generating facilities that
became operational after September 1 of
2024 um I do not anticipate C Brook
would be able to take part in this um
under this in take part in the RPS under
this amendment as it is an existing
generation
facility
you have a question for Mr robers I do
okay go ahead thanks um thank you Mr
robers for taking my question good
morning um so my question is how much
Rex actually um go for at this point in
other words if we had you know a 300
megawatt plant that ended up having
output capacity that dwarfs all other
Renewables that are in the that new
category um they would likely be taking
most of if not all of the recks but I
I'm curious how much of an incentive it
actually is because I don't think the
recks in the state are very valuable at
this point so I'd like to know what a
wreck is worth at this point sure and
thank you for the question so and how
many of them are in circulation because
I don't think we know that either sure
so some of that information is in an
annual report um that we kick out every
year um if it's helpful I can find the
page and forward it along after um after
um I'd have to talk internally as to
what the current kind of going prices
for class one Rex um it's not something
I oh sorry um I don't know off the top
of my head that's something I need to
dig a little bit deeper in and follow up
with the K by an email if that's all
right and follow up um and how many are
there like how does that get determined
because I know it's in the reporting but
I don't think we know it off the top of
our heads and I don't either so but I I
know that that number is in the report
and I can find that number and follow up
with the committee yep thank
you
you have a question for Mr Roberge or or
another
comment okay representative Thomas thank
you very much Mr chair um Mr robers can
you tell us what are the guard rails for
any new nuclear builds and is that under
your office or is it under Dees and
what's to keep a new nuclear plant from
becoming the new St gobain of New
Hampshire sure so thank you for the
question so for any new nuclear facility
there there are a number of permits that
I imagine that facility might need such
as say uh going through Dees permitting
Nation uh nuclear Regulatory Commission
that type of thing I'm certainly not an
expert on every single permit that um
such a resource would need
um yeah again it it is kind of a
hypothetical I can't predict what the
future might hold um but I imagine yes
permitting will be requ IR ired for any
type of permit that comes on in the
you representative Kennedy question for
not okay okay representative Harrington
a question for Mr robers well actually
more of a followup to his question as
far as the permitting goes it's
exclusive purview of the NRC to license
uh nuclear plants in the United States
it's it's completely Federal but there
are various permits that are involved
from the state Dees would be involved if
there was a water discharge permit for
example uh usually there's a coolant
system involved they'd be involved in
that if there was any air emissions a
lot of these plants have a diesel
generator emergency diesel generator
associated with it um and also they may
even have something else to uh what they
use to start up that would involve uh
air discharge so there are some state
permits but the biggest one is going to
be the NRC first the design has to be
licensed uh by the NRC and then there's
a specific license that would have to be
granted for the construction and
operation of a plant by the NRC again
and that takes multiple years to
get all right I'm going to cut it off
there and let you go because I think we
need to wrap up this discussion here
pretty quickly we've got two other bills
that we
need work session I was trying to get a
comment in before okay what is your
quick comment please yeah so I just
wanted to uh mention we we've discussed
a number of different nuclear
technologies I read an article this
weekend on um the viability of pulling
uranium from the ocean which is would be
would make nuclear renewable so they are
working on that but in its current state
the types of reactors that are currently
Allowed by the NRC for permitting are
not considered renewable and so although
Connecticut has gone this way and I
don't know their decision- making was I
still think for my point that I made
with Mr
robar um Rex would not be a significant
incentive for something as expensive as
bringing in a nuclear reactor right that
it would be the offset to the kind of
cost that would be involved would be
very minimal so I don't think that this
is the nod to say that we're um look
interested in nuclear I don't think that
this is going to assist in any way but
it will red Define what we interpret to
be renewable in the state and I and I
don't think that that's a good idea and
I don't think that it will be helpful to
the RPS so I would like to recommend
that we either is this or we itl this
and we let um representative
Harrington's bill for interim study on
where the RPS is moving be a place where
we have this discussion because I don't
think the bill is ready to become law
that's just that's how I see it thank
you did you have one more comment
representative Kennedy I see your hand
up I would have a many comments about
all right so you don't okay you're gonna
you're going to stand down all right
let's move on then and
uh have a discussion about HB
1431 we have a couple of amendments for
that representative Kaplan has an
amendment let's talk about his Amendment
first um the amendment
so uh what I'm passing out now Mr chair
is a slight modification on my original
Amendment so it's basically cleaning it
up a little bit so are you passing out
0609 H I believe so yeah so what I'm
passing out is 0609 H okay I also have
20 copies of it here I don't know why I
have all these copies okay if anybody
out there would like a copy of this
amendment we have lots up here so please
come get one for a very reasonable
now so I mean I'd like to go through the
changes on this amendment from the
original Amendment which I shared at the
public
hearing so there's basically three
changes on this new
Amendment and the first one is that uh
the word transmission has been taken out
okay so everywhere
the the word transmission occurred in
the original amendment is is now just
reads distribution okay so we're just
talking about distribution lines not
transmission lines because the feedback
in the public hearing
was pretty consistent that transmission
lines are a federal prerogative and
don't belong in the puc's domain so took
out transmission line transmission lines
from the equation
the second change that occurs is on
page
two line 36 and it's in it's talking
about the enforceability mechanism of
this integrated plan Bill and uh I added
the word Distribution on line 36 so it
says it reads now no distribution rate
change shall be approved uh in the case
where there's no plan on file so we we
heard feedback from Mr Fran that that
would be a red flag if uh if the default
rate cases were impacted by by this
mechanism so took out the default rate
cases from the equation and now it's
just distribution rate changes that was
that uh can cannot be approved if
file okay that's it no there's one
there's one more
page line 30 line uh 26 sorry I've added
in at the behest of the community power
Coalition people uh added in competitive
choice of electricity suppliers
consistent with RSA
374f uh as uh into the list of things
that need to be included in the plan so
that's that's offering the option of
considering the growth of community
power and the impact that that would
have on on their planning on the
planning of the utilities so those are
amendment I'm Sor oh yeah that the
original Amendment also added gas so
that still that still is in here the
that gas lines or the gas utilities are
included can you please go over the
first okay change thank you uh
representative Kaplan questions
representative Thomas yes can you just
clarify that the first change that you
mentioned
regarding transmission yeah okay well on
uh there every time there was the word
distribution there also
occurred and transmission so now the
word transmission has been taken out you
won't see that in this
amendment okay so for instance on line
15 submission of integrated electric
distribution plans to the commission
originally that read distribution and
transmission plans
Okay so we've taken out transmission
equation additional questions for
representative Kaplan representative
McGee I didn't have a question um for
representative Kaplan I I wanted to just
provide a little bit of context as well
because um this amendment is trying to
address language that was removed uh
last session when we passed HB
281 and that was the least cost
integrated resource planning statute at
the time of the Senate hearing um we
were looking at sort of an Omnibus Bill
with five different bills that were
pulled together one of those sections
was to repeal um the least cost
integrated resource planning and at that
time um a discussion was had that the
definition um of New Hampshire energy
policy which appears under 378
837 uh was not something that we wanted
to repeal with everything else and it it
would have in its state so we the bill
was amended to ensure that that language
which appears in this amendment from
line nine to line
14 um with I guess there were some
modifications in there I don't know you
could probably speak to that they were
in the original Amendment you had you
had changed that updated that language
but what it does is um it preserves what
we were discussing in those hearings in
terms of the energy policy statement uh
that's been on the books for a long time
and so uh this particular
Amendment um goes further in that it
takes the other subsections which were
eliminated altogether and brings back
the language that actually requires uh
our Regulators to be looking at um
long-term planning and integrated
planning which is probably more
important than ever because as the
system is changing and getting more
complex um you know it's really
important that The Regulators understand
what the utilities are doing and that
the utilities be able to explain how
they're keeping costs low for people so
even though it's not called a least cost
integrated resource planning statute
anymore it is still uh the way it's
written here devoted to the idea of of
pushing least cost or or cost impacts
need to be addressed in those in those
uh proceedings so I just wanted to put
some context around why the bill where
the bill came from and
um for your consideration that's
all okay further discussion now I know
that during the public hearing on this
bill there was some mentioned
that gas
utility regulation is not under the
control of the Pu
and it may not be appropriate in this
that I I don't recall those comments
being made Mr chair to be
honest was it just transmission yeah
transmission was an issue okay correct
all right I don't have my notes right in
front
unfortunately all right further
discussion representative Harrington I
had a couple of questions on the on the
bill
seems to be let me just read it and know
um if you go to line 12 it talks about
the various things that the state's
utilities while providing for says the
use of cost effective Energy Efficiency
and other demand side
resources protection of the safe uh
safety and health of the citizens and
finally physical environment of the
state and the future supplies of
resources well the first thing I guess
I'd comment on there there's nothing
about coste Effectiveness as as far as
rates go it just talks about coste
effective use of costeffective Energy
Efficiency um I don't know what the
future supplies of resources implies but
later on when you go down to line 18 it
does talk about necessary to improve
cost Effectiveness so could you clarify
that yeah I mean I think uh thank you
for the thank you for the comment
representative
Harrington I think when it comes to the
cost Effectiveness in in the uh energy
policy definition on you know 3 378 call
37 uh
that when you look at the language
around Financial stability of the
state's
utilities you know the whole the whole
mechanism of of the of the rate changes
is to guarantee the financial stability
of the utilities and that is
included pretty much up front as a first
principle okay so it is included in
there reasonable and fair electric and
gas rates that consider the financial
stability of the state utilities I I I
find that a pretty clear statement of
the need to take care of the utilities
and their business
model including the rate
case any more
questions what followup go ahead what is
the future supplies of resources implied
at the very last part of line 14 yeah I
mean you don't have a picture of that
neither do I because it's in the future
um but I think that has to do you know
the way I read that it has to do with
diversity of of uh of energy resources
to try to minimize risk going forward
and so that's how I read it anyways
future supplies of resources means we
need to think about the future and what
resources are in the basket of resources
that we have at the moment and you know
how that's going to look going forward
so when you s resources you're talking
about uh generation and uh demand
reduction yeah okay so I'm I'm just a
little confused on that the so you're
saying the utility then should plan
going out to say uh if I go out for for
default Service rates I better make sure
I don't get too much of X gen type of
generation because maybe there won't be
enough of that around in the future but
maybe I should get more of Y I'm a
little confused on what that
implies well I mean we're talking about
10year plans so uh default rate cases
usually more shortterm than that but um
so yeah they need to look at what are
the impacts of their programs and you
know how that plays out on a 10-year
scale so if they are currently invested
heavily in you know transmission and
distribution line or distribution lines
that are are uh appropriate for a
certain technology and not for another
technology maybe they uh you know look
at what that what the implications of
does that help
you not really no further questions
comments
Etc okay seeing
none I guess we now have a understanding
of Representative kaplan's
Amendment and I am now circulating an
own which is is
amendment
H and this
amendment is different from
representative kaplan's
amendment in that it amends the original
Bill his Amendment
0609 amends a previous
Amendment right representative Kaplan
right so this this
amendment
um just amends the original Bill and it
does so by
rewriting sections 3 four and five that
Bill and
then on page two of the original
bill it changes on line8 the number six
to the number three so that the text
would read the utility will have three
months to amend and resubmit rather than
six months those are the changes that my
uh amendment
makes the rewrite of uh lines 23 through
30 of the original bill that
are lines 3 through eight of the
amendment uh essentially just
remove some language about grid modif
that what we're looking for here is an
assessment of distribution
infrastructure necessary to ensure a
reliable and resilient Electric System
capable of meeting the forecasted
customer customer
demand
so uh and then of course the rewrite of
section five on line 28 in the original
Bill Now talks about an assessment of
the plan's integration and consistency
with the state energy strategy and
removes references to
environmental and
and price
um those situations with the utilities
and the public commiss uh Utilities
Commission told us they don't have the
wherewithal
to assess what long and short-term
environmental and economic conditions
are going to be so we took put uh took
those out of the uh
Amendment so that is the amendment that
I'm going to offer for HB
1431 and uh enjo entertain your comments
representative Ms so this um so your
Amendment would would um keep the bill
as only addressing Electric utilities
nothing for Gas Utilities correct okay
additional
comments representative
Thomas uh yes I just have tremendous
concerns about removing um the
environment excuse
me the environmental impact um I I just
think that's that's so dangerous and
we've seen instances already in New
Hampshire where the environment has not
been protected from corporations and
problems I think the uh concern that was
expressed during the public hearing was
that if you open this up to
environmental
impacts then these uh the adjudications
adjudicate the deliberations on these
plans would never end because the number
of environmental impacts long and short
term is virtually
endless and as a result of that these
plans would never get approved because
the proceedings would drag on for
potentially years while all
these while every Environmental Group in
the world brought its
concerns uh to the commission about
these these plans so it it's it's going
to make the bill and the the legislation
unworkable
to leave that in there I understand your
concerns and I I share them but I don't
think this is the right place to be
addressing those
concerns representative
rolds thank you Mr chairman
um I um I agree with I agree with you on
that
um I think that if we are attempting to
reinstate a
reasonable um
process for our state's Electric
utilities
to you know do this kind of
planning manage the evolution of the
electric grid toward a more
um you know disaggregated uh system more
decentralized sources of Supply
um I um I think we should keep
it we should limit it to that and there
are I think that there are lots of there
are
other um other venues and other other
permitting processes that that would um
suffice to protect the
environment um you
know yeah I just I think um we should
keep it tight I like your um Amendment
where you're collapsing the timeline and
required from you know letting these
letting the planning drag on to a year
rather um make it um
shorter so that
um so that the process be stays
meaningful and isn't you know just
interminable thank you additional
comments representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman um um I think I I I uh could
agree with removing maybe the plans long
and short term but I I don't see us
saying that
any uh forward reaching Planning by the
utilities should go in front of an
adjudicative body one of the only that
it goes in front of without any
assessment of environmental Public
Health economic and energy price in
impacts on the state because those are
all the things that the people we work
for care about right they care care
about whether their environment is going
to be negatively impacted and their own
health and they care about the economics
of what we're doing with energy and also
the price impacts and so if we remove
that language what we're saying is we'll
just trust that all that's going to
happen without us giving any um any
guidance to The Regulators in terms of
the expectation that those plans will be
looked at in that light and so I think
that's really important language I think
the thing for consideration is that the
additional language that is in the
amendment that representative Kaplan
brought would be lost if we adopt this
amendment so all of the other um efforts
to restate how we would be approaching
um electric and utility electric utility
and natural gas utility integrated
planning would not be covered so we
would we would lose um language that I
think is also
reinstate repres Vice chair Thomas thank
you Mr chair I um so correct me if I'm
wrong but uh wouldn't things such as
environmental concerns be the subject of
whatever sighting process might be going
on at the time should should something
new uh come up I mean uh there there
must be other avenues we have in the
state that handles environmental
concerns um besides what was in here so
I would think our normal process would
anyway representative
Harrington yeah just first I'd like to
make sure I'm clear on what the bill is
actually doing so you're going back not
to the amendment we received today but
to the original bill as introduced
correct say again we we're dealing with
changes to the original bill as
introduced correct we have two Amendment
proposals
so we looking on here then
um 378 colon 37 stays the same there's
no change to that that stays the same as
in the original Bill yes and then in 38
we change sections three four and five
everything else stays the
same it's correct correct okay and then
on the the uh last page of the bill as
submitted 39 we replace 39 completely
with a new
correct no the amendment that I've
proposed doesn't change anything in 39
except the number
six in the original Bill my Amendment
one other than that language is the same
you you say amend
37839 one as inserted by section two of
the bill by replacing it with the
following so you're replacing
that whole paragraph correct but the
only change is the number to three six
is changed to a three for the purposes
of drafting the OS attorney thought that
replacing the whole paragraph okay was
the way go in order to change that and
then section two and as well as 37840
remain as in the original Bill correct
okay and one last question why was gas
taken out since it's a regulated utility
as
well I took out gas because
uh well actually I didn't take anything
out what I did is I amended the original
bill which did not have gas in it so
that's the expl for uh explanation for
that representative
muds um and I apologize if I missed this
in your um your introduction of the bill
um but in um in the original Bill lines
on page one lines 23 through
25 which you are
amending that the original Bill includes
says that such a assessments such
assessments shall include consideration
of the benefits and costs of grid
modernization you you you are deleting
that can you kind of give us some
that I think that
uh goes beyond the scope of what a
distribution plan is all
about that is a subject that I think is
beond beyond the scope of of what one of
these plans can do and would lead to
protracted discussions that would delay
the approval of the plan just like
environmental
considerations followup but isn't the
but isn't the grid the distribution
Network
so why wouldn't the grid is but
modernizing the grid is not something
that a distribution plan is going to
discuss it would Implement
modernization requests or or
requirements as they uh are
imposed representative Ms um but this is
you know this is another word for a
strategic plan and you know if if the
grid is not going to meet the needs
of the future shouldn't that be included
it could be I suppose but doesn't I
don't think it needs to be because it
just opens a door that might take many
close representative McGee thank you um
yeah I mean I think that this
distributed integrated distributed
Planning by the utilities uh the whole
point I think is for them to be doing
that planning and looking at that
strategy or strategic as as
representative mun said so I'm wondering
if we could have Mr Lata come up to
speak to whether or not it's potentially
burdensome to have grid modernization as
something that they should at least be
nodding to when they present these plans
because I I think it's appropriate I
don't know where else we would have it
and that was one of the discussions that
came up when we decided to eliminate the
least cost integrated resource planning
language was that we needed some
language that took the the the larger
view rather than just um you know uh
what you're putting in today but
basically tell us how this is going to
play with uh longer term thinking around
the stability of the grid itself or the
um modernization of the grid so I I
don't see where else those things would
be taken into consideration and if
there's no dialogue between the
regulators and the utilities on that and
no statutory requirement for there to be
Dialogue on that then I think we I think
we lose something really essential so
could we could we ask um since we have a
rep of our largest utility here yes I
will ask him in just a moment but first
I'd react to your your comment by saying
that it will never be discussed uh in
one of these resource plans because it's
not defined what is grid modernization
my understanding of grid modernization
is it could be literally hundreds of
different things and without a def
definition and a and a some specificity
in this language about grid
modernization you're looking at an
approval process for one of these plans
it could take years so I I just don't
see how you can do this without a
definition of what grid modernization is
because it's a broad umbrella term that
means hundreds of different
things so repres Mr Lata uh to uh allow
representative McGee to ask you a
forward representative Harrington yeah I
I think we had a group didn't we
establish a group an Advisory Group on
grid modernization by Statute last year
that I thought yes we did so we do have
an active group working on this so it's
not like we're we were just ignoring it
just wanted people to realize that
correct representative
McGee thank you yes so uh to get back to
grid modernization I think is fairly
well established at least in the
utilities Community um and so Mr
Lata uh if you could tell us whether
having the term grid modernization as it
appears in the bill as originally
written is in any way burdensome in
terms of um when you present a
plan uh I mean grid modernization could
be updating technology different types
of meters could be um you know uh
interconnection points it could be it
could be many different things but um
does having an overall term that creates
a bucket for consideration does that
create a burden for the utilities or is
it something you already do sure I um I
think representative Harrington
appropriately pointed out that um last
year the legislature had passed uh
uh legislation creating a grid
modernization advisory committee and
that actually is the reference to
statute uh that that's in the bill um in
terms of so I I agree with um
representative Harrington's point that
there is a venue for conversations
around grid
modernization uh at the state level and
quite frankly the the output of that
committee would be informing um some of
the work that the Committees would that
the utilities would do as part of this
this long-term planning I I don't think
that it is um necessary to have grid
modernization as it's uh in the bill
called out in order for the utilities to
capture um you know work that they're
doing in this area I do agree with
representative Vose that um you know the
term grid modernization although it is
uh linked back back statute here can
mean a lot of different things to a lot
of different people even within the
utility space um one might look at that
from a metering perspective one might
look at it from Smart switches so
there's there is a lot there and I am um
sensitive to the concerns raised by uh
some of the committee members and the
doe of
protracted um uh proceedings I I would
point out um just maybe to hopefully
assuage folks concerns on that uh later
in the bill it does require the Pu
render a decision either to approve or
deny a plan within 12 months so we don't
want protracted you know lengthy
proceedings that go on on forever as
well as I don't think the doe and
commission would either so so there is
sort of a back stop on the end here to
to keep it from becoming a um sort of a
fishing Expedition but um I think that
you know quite frankly the removal of
that language um is is not harmful to
the bill it's not harmful to utility
planning and if it you know assuages
some concerns with the bill about that
protracted um uh efforts I think it's
removal follow up thank you so was this
language part of the original
LCP no it was not so grid modernization
was not included in the strategic
planning basically that we had in place
before correct so it's a new thing that
that's that's correct okay thank you
that helps welcome all right thank you
representative Ms you have a question
for Mr Lata yes I do okay thank you um
thank you for taking my question um are
um um interconnects to EV charging
stations is that considered
distribution yes that's that's done at
the distribution level but that's that
would be that would be part of the
distribution Network and that would be
included in a a a um integrated
distribution planning so so process yeah
the short answer is is yes and um as I I
previously testified we would be happy I
know there was a discussion about
presentations in the future um to the
committee and again I'd be happy to have
our planning folks come out and talk
about the work that they do and how they
do it um in terms of a 10-year forecast
which is what we're talking about here
they look at at sort of industry and
population and and economic Trends so
there is data that they would access
independent um forecasts on say electric
vehicle growth charging stations
required to accommodate that where those
charging stations might be located say
the 93 Corridor you know if if there's
um you know a desire to to support the
tourism industry and you know have those
folks come up from Massachusetts so
that's done at a sort of a high level
planning uh perspective but we don't
start building until you know we get an
actual customer request we do an
assessment of that we we do an
evaluation of the impact um of that
interconnection just like we would with
a PV station PV installation and there
are costs associated with that
installation that are born by the
developer seeking um that
interconnection so I hope that helps
followup followup no that makes perfect
sense to me I guess what I what I was
trying to get at was you know we we've
been talking about you know language and
definitions and um you know we can't
include the term grid modernization
because that has all sorts of different
connotations I just wanted to make sure
that if we say
distribution that you know two years
from now or whatever when we see a plan
and it doesn't dress interconnect
somebody says well no that's not part of
the distribution system so that that was
my question no no understood and um
whether it's it's positive
growth from increased economic activity
um customers choosing different options
for either heating or or
Transportation uh or on the other end of
the scale um investments in Energy
Efficiency or economic downturns
whatever it might be that that depress
uh growth
load that would be contained within um
the first assessment which is um you
know a comprehensive forecast of the
10-year energy uh demand and that's
that's something that you know the
commission can we say look under the
hood and and question those assumptions
uh and say well hold on a second you
know why are you assuming this shouldn't
you be considering that and and just to
point out that you know one of the
reasons we're supportive of this is um
you know both from a a utility
perspective but I would say also from
the customer perspective as well um
absent this uh uh regulatory framework
that allows the commission and the
department of energy and consumer
Advocate to to see those assumptions the
next time that they're going to have an
opportunity to to essentially see our
growth plans and how we're we're meeting
them is during a rate case after we have
built that infrastructure and from a
customer perspective you know I I can't
speak to any Regulators in the room but
I know we have a former one sitting up
at the table um you know once the
utility has built something and and is
seeking cost recovery it becomes harder
for for a disallowance at that point as
opposed to if we come in earlier there's
more opportunity for the regulator to
push back on it because there isn't the
financial detriment um to the utility so
it allows for that earlier sort of
realignment with the commission before
money is spent which ultimately is is I
think good for the customer as well as
as the utility obviously but it it it is
a for of I I would say rapair
protection okay great thanks we don't
need you to repeat your testimony from
your from the original Bill uh
representative Corman thank you uh so Mr
Lata earlier we were discussing um a an
item that would be omitted in
representative Bose's Amendment and it
was the line that says an assessment of
the plan's long and short-term
Environmental economic and energy price
impact on the state that's in in the
bill as
introduced um I'm wondering uh if you
can comment on on those I guess three
items here uh whether ever Source has a
uh an opinion on on including
environmental economic and energy price
impact in the plan sure uh so I think
it's very important to remember what
we're talking about with these
plans the
distribution uh utilities eversource
Unitil and um the Electric Co-op
although they're not subject to this and
and Liberty we're talking about poles
wires
Transformers smart switches um so when
you're looking at the environmental
impacts of this plan we're really
talking about that street level
infrastructure and so you know this
isn't power plants this isn't you know
the utility making determinations about
shutting down a a gas plant or or um you
know really Supply concerns there so we
have to comply with all the state uh
environmental laws and obviously all the
Federal Environmental laws when we are
building our infrastructure we have to
go get Wetland permits alteration of
terrain permits um you know the whole
Gambit and so I I do agree with the
comment that was previously said that
there are many other I think it was
representative Rani there are many other
venues for environmental considerations
of utility infrastructure and if we were
to propose a significant pro pro um
project um that would be subject to the
site evaluation committee review process
um so so just to you know maybe put that
into context in terms of the economic
and energy price impact um quite frankly
this is what the Public Utilities
Commission does that's the the purpose
of the commission is to weigh the
interest of of customers and the utility
through through an economic lens and so
you know removing that I don't think
weakens this I don't think it weakens
the review the the Pu is going to have
cost uh front and center on this and I
think I would also point out you know at
the end of the day they need to find
that that our rates that our decisions
are just reasonable and in the public
interest so so I am not concerned with
the removal of that again if it uh
addresses concerns that that folks have
um then then I think it's it's worth
removal okay thanks a lot Mr Lata I
appreciate it we're going to have to
move on and talk about 1465 for a few
minutes before we uh
shut down this full committee work
session obviously during the exec
session we can have further discussions
but representative Ms I'd like you to
pass out your amendment to
1465 so that we can talk about this for
a few minutes before we break for a
lunch so please start explaining the
amendment while it's uh moving around
the table okay um
I um I I spoke with um representative o
and representative Harrington and we
also consulted with the um the
department of energy uh as well as the
prime sponsor on this bill on this
amendment and um I think I would
characterize this amendment as just
trying to to to clean up some things and
maybe clarify some things um and
hopefully not um making too many
significant um policy
changes um the the one thing that we did
is uh clarify that the um uh
Commissioner of um of uh the department
of energy is um the the senior advisor
as it relates to um uh nuclear uh
policy um and in probably the most
significant step we created a um
coordinator of nuclear development and
Regulatory
activities um to
um you know o oversee a lot of the U
responsibilities that are now kind of
now dispersed among different
departments um the responsibility of
that Coordinator would be to uh that
that Coordinator would be the person
that would be responsible for pulling
together together the report that's
required in statute
currently um and they would be asking
for input from the various departments
the way the bill is structured now is
that each of those departments has to
produce a report and it seemed a little
bit um
redundant um the other thing that the
the amendment does is put the um
coordinator of nuclear development and
um regulat activities puts that position
in the office of what is currently
called the offshore wind industry devel
the office of offshore wind industry
development um and then what the
amendment does is it renames that office
the office of in energy in intervention
or innovation sorry um and um to address
concerns that um the department and um
and and and others working on this had
about the the budget impact of doing all
of this what we have done is set the
effective date for the bill or the
amendment to be June 30th of
2025 which gives the um Department time
to get a budget request in if they feel
that there is additional
costs um there is an opportunity to get
money into the next budget which would
be proposed next January and would
presumably be in effect by July 1 of
2025 so they're they they would then
have the resources that they need to
implement this although it's not
included in the in in the amendment um
the discussions that we did have were
that this office of energy Innovation
would
become the place where um new and
Innovative energy um
solutions could be vetted uh
analyzed um we talked about in addition
to it including offshore wind and
nuclear it could potentially be the
place where all um studies relating to
hydrogen battery storage you know other
any other Innovative um Technologies
would be um reviewed and um
and and
analyzed so I think that's it I don't
know if representative Harrington or Vos
add I do not representative Harrington
yeah a couple of things um on the first
page line 26 it says the Public
Utilities Commission I don't see that
they would have anything to do with the
nuclear whatsoever and also on line 28
talks about his the participation by
public utilities subject to the
jurisdiction again utilities don't make
generation in New Hampshire so they
wouldn't be involved in this um the
other question I have and I'm not sure
the answer on this one uh Department of
Transportation talks about the
transportation of special nuclear
materials on the highways of the state I
understand that's regulated by the
federal government I don't know if the
state gets involved we already do have
that that this is not a looking to the
Future thing we have special nuclear
materials being moved because we refuel
uh at least we were refueling at the
Portsmouth Naval Shipyard um so they
have to I think the fuel comes in
through New Hampshire even though it's
in Maine and we also uh refuel seab
Brook so that would be special nucal
material I just don't know if there's
any involvement there at all at this
point I I know the feds regulate that
quite extensively but I don't know if
the Department of Transportation has
anything to do with it the coordinator
can I can I respond to that
sure representative months yeah that the
the language that you see on page one
starting at line 19 all the way through
the second page on line 10 I mean that
is language that already exists in
statute I just carried it forward so I
mean you may you I'm not going to
question you know whether I mean there
may be some issues there um you know
Department of Transportation I'm
assuming that that gets at exactly what
you talked about I mean the
transportation of nule material to the
kidy shipyard KY uh the na the
Portsmouth Naval Yard and and seab Brook
um but that language that that's
existing language there was no changes
there y just copied it
over
exactly so representative Ms could you
Amendment replaces uh section two of the
original bill that appears on page two
starting at line
five yeah it it replaces section two uh
as you said starting on page two line
five
um it also replaces section
four which starts on page two at line
22 and then it
um
it
changes section
five with the language that's included
in the amendment on page three starting
at line 19 that talks about you know the
the office of windshore energy
development
um
and
um I know that
the sponsor was very concerned
about um Advanced nuclear reactors so it
it it does not change paragraph
three in the original bill that def that
talks about that that's still in the
bill but what I'm concerned about now
looking at this
eliminate the new the definition of n
Advanced nuclear that's on in the
original bill on page
three I don't think so it uh adds
sections after section five of the bill
but it doesn't replace section five okay
yep thank you thank thank you thank you
there so it changes section two it
changes section four and then it adds
these these additional sections at the
end that just do the housekeeping of
changing the name of the office of
energy of of offshore wind to energy
Innovation and that's all it does it
just changes the name that's that
there's nothing no increase in the scope
or anything okay great representative
Kaplan has a question or a comment thank
you chairman yeah I I need some
clarification on uh page four of the
amendment is this new uh starting on
line three the the establishment of a
renewable energy fund that's not in the
original bill is it that's not in the
original Bill and that is that's not new
that's existing language the only thing
that's being done in that whole sect
Roman numeral one there is changing the
name um on line
14 okay thank you representative Thomas
has a comment or question yes I do thank
you Mr chair I have uh two questions
clarification questions first of all um
we heard uh some comment earlier that
the nrc's purview covers nuclear
facilities so would this commission link
arms with the NRC is there any mechanism
for that
and my second question is the fiscal
note does this um Amendment at all alter
the fiscal note thank
you uh again I mean I I I I don't think
it changes anything in terms of the
state's relationship with the nuclear
Regulatory Commission um really all
we're doing is establishing a a a
position in the state to kind of
coordinate all of that so if anything it
maybe it it makes it more efficient in
terms of how the state interacts with
the nuclear Regulatory Commission and
then um in terms of the um fiscal note
um
um I I I I I don't have the answer to
that other than I'm assuming that since
we're um delaying the financial impact
until you know a future budget year that
there really is no fiscal impact this
year
okay additional comments representative
Harrington yeah I I realize uh what the
um uh sponsor of this bill was trying to
do but I just think there's so much
stuff baggage hanging on this that it
really needs to be cleaned up
substantially I mean if you look on
um the paragraph that was just mentioned
there the department of energy cells
studies state and federal policies
technology Supply chains and potential
sighting locations related to Advanced
nuclear reactors well that could take
four people four years or maybe longer
it is wide open it there's no I mean I
don't what would they be studying it's
we don't have a department of energy
that's staffed up to look into uh all of
all of this stuff and to to come up with
sighting locations I meaning all that's
going to be done by a private company if
and when they ever decide they want to
come to New Hampshire so that's uh
that's one thing and then part of the
other stuff if you look at uh going back
to the original bill which I think this
is still in the original bill on page
two as well line starting on line seven
says conduct studies concerning changes
in laws and rules and it goes on to talk
about that would arise from the presence
within the state of special nuclear
materials and product materials and from
the operation herein on production of
utilization of facilities and blah blah
blah this I assume was put in way back
before we had any nuclear facilities in
the state and if and when this law was
complied to it's already been done
whatever administrative rules we decided
we needed are put in place and we've
like I said we've always been dealing
with special nuclear material in the
state for a number of years and uh I'm
not sure why we're going back and
redoing apparently is what they want
this to be redone uh we don't even know
if it's been done in the first place so
I just think this bill needs a lot of
work before we do this and like I say
assigning that study state and federal
policies blah blah blah blah blah that
could be that could be a whole
department just to do that I mean it
just it's we need to really trim the
stuff down find out what has been done
what hasn't been done what doesn't need
to be done so I just mentioned it does
talk about the Public Utilities
Commission in there uh which has no
jurisdiction over any nuclear
transactions whatsoever it talks about
the public utilities which again in our
state where we have no have vertically
integrated utilities no Public Utilities
going to be making and going to be
building a nuclear plant these are
things that are in the bill that are
dated from whenever this was originally
written 30 or 40 years ago and I just
think before we put out a bill that
appears to bring things up to speed when
only we're doing is changing a few names
we this this needs a lot more
work representative
parall thank you chair and um I agree
totally with the remarks of our uh of
the person to my left here um one other
question I would like to ask of him if I
may though is uh the cost of this
program when we' just received um some
dire warnings about uh Revenue coming
into the state and the expenses we're
already putting on the book does this
add additional expense to uh program
that we're looking that doesn't really
have a good definition to begin
with I may Mr chairman I think that
question was answered earlier when it
was pointed out that this bill wouldn't
take effect until after 2025 June 1st or
June 30th or something to know it would
have no immediate financial impact but
eventually if it's as written if it
stays on the books it would require an
awful lot of studies and Analysis and
stuff to do that and that is potentially
true that is potentially true so this is
an early Bill we have to make a decision
about it today today is our last
opportunity to make a decision on this
bill so I just alert you to that fact as
we uh prepare for our executive session
at 1:00 and with that I think we're
going to uh suspend our full committee
work session activity for the time
being and I'm going to call a republican
caucus in this room immediately so I
would appreciate everyone exiting the
room as quickly as
possible after the uh caucus is over
then we're on lunch break until 1:00 and
we will see you all at 1:00 thank you
very
much
for
okay everyone time to get back to work
here science technology and energy for
February 13 2024 we have an executive
session coming up on three
bills and those three bills will be
taken in this order the first bill we
will exact is HB
1465 FN relative to studies of nuclear
Energy
Technologies then we will move on to hb1
1644 which will have a new title and
1431 are there any uh announcements that
need to be made before we start our exec
sessions representative
bernardy thank you Mr chair uh we had
the discussion about our field trip to
ISO New England which was tentatively
scheduled for the 12th of March and as
we discussed this morning that happens
to be town meeting day for many many
folks so the alternative date now is 15
March that's
Friday so so uh I will need a recount
from everybody on their availability and
uh you can mull that over and maybe at
the end of executive session we can get
account of those that know and those
that are still
thinking excellent thank
you okay with that out of the way let's
now open an exec session on House Bill
1465 FN relative to studies of nuclear
energy Technologies chair recognizes
Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr chair uh
I motion to adopt Amendment 202
24-65 50h chair recognizes
representative Bernardi I second that
motion moved and seconded that we adopt
Amendment 20240
650h for House Bill
1465 discussion Vice chair Thomas thank
you Mr chair it's a good amendment pass
comments
well looks like we have none oh there's
representative
parial yes thank you chair I would also
like to I would like to say that I still
have cost concerns uh for technology
it's untried to require another employee
at the department of uh
energy this bill was or this amendment
rather has been vetted by the department
of energy and they found it to be
acceptable
discussion seeing none i' ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of the
06508 Vice chair Thomas yes
representative n yes representative
Harrington
no representative Ley yes representative
brne yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative uh
cambrell
yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
MC Williams yes
representative crean yes there
Representative parshall
no representative
Kaplan yes representative
muns yes representative Noel yes
representative Thomas no representative
Corman yes representative rolds
yes chairman Vose
yes
170 173 excuse me okay by a vote of 17
to3 Amendment
2024 06
50h is adopted chair recognizes
representative Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr chair I motion uh
otpa chair recognizes representative
Bernardi I second the motion moved and
seconded that we adopt the motion of
ought to pass as amended on House Bill
dfn as amended by Amendment 2024
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of ought to pass as amended on House
Bill
1465 Vice chair Thomas yes
representative n yes representative
Harrington no representative licki yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative cels
yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee
yes representative MC Williams yes
representative cran yes Representative
parshall no representative Kaplan yes
representative muns yes representative
Noel yes representative
Thomas no representative
Corman yes representative rolds yes
chairman Vose yes 173 by a vote of 17-3
the committee adopts house
bill or the motion of oop pass is
amended on House Bill
H Vice chair Thomas will write the
committee report unless there is a
Minority Report I think there will be I
repres will there be a Minority
Report speak on the floor should be aort
okay I I'll give you a a report okay
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas will
um write a report and we need that
report before you leave the building
today oh
[Laughter]
mind you can change your mind well so I
I need to type it so can I can I go home
and type it and send it to you we would
prefer not this is an early bill and we
need this uh these committee reports
ASAP okay all right I got you I got it I
got
it okay so we're all set with that then
all right so let's close the exact
1465 and now we'll move on to House Bill
1644 I'll open that exec session and I
0610 and I recognize representative
licki I second that motion moved in
second seconded that we adopt Amendment
610h to House Bill
1644 I will start the discussion by
this amendment which adds nuclear
powered generating facilities to the
RPS is not technically a renewable form
of
energy there is so much renewable energy
I mean U nuclear energy fuel out there
that it will be almost virtually
renewable I'll also point out that the
evolution of the renewable portfolio
standard will likely mean that it
becomes a zero emissions portfolio
standard at some point in the not too
distant
future what I think this this amendment
will do is send a loud and clear message
to the people of New Hampshire that this
legislature is open to considering
nuclear power as a future generation
Source now we all know that nuclear
power is not perfect it has its it has
its issues and problems but they're not
insoluble un insolvable I should say and
there are many many companies working on
new nuclear technologies that will be
far superior to what exists here today
but I think it's important for New
Hampshire to be on record as saying that
we are open to nuclear generated
electricity going
forward not only are we open to it but
we recognize the imperative that nuclear
energy is very likely to become a
significant part of our
legislation
representative Thomas thank you Mr chair
um during the discussion of the bill I
raised um concern about um putting out a
sign that says New Hampshire is open for
business for uh nuclear energy admitted
that that there's nothing in the
immediate future however um I believe
it's the cart before the horse I mean
unless we put significant guard rails in
and I realize the nuclear regulation
committee is in in charge of that or
oversees that I just I'm I'm telling you
I've got PTSD from St gobain and I just
do not see putting in other corporations
that could potentially affect the
community without significant
oversight further discussion
representative
Kennedy yeah I just wanted to point out
which I think already has been that the
NRC regulates nuclear power power and
they are the most stringent agency you
could imagine I mean they virtually
halted all nuclear development for like
30 years so I think it will be looked at
you know very thoroughly before anything
is
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of the adoption of the amendment 20240
610h
Vice chair Thomas yes representative
naer yes representative Harrington yes
representative licki yes representative
Brey yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
cambrell yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
MC Williams yes representative crean yes
representative parall yes representative
Kaplan yes representative muns yes
representative Nel yes representative
Thomas no representative Corman yes
representative rolds yes chairman Vose
yes
191 with the vote of 19 to1 in the
affirmative the committee adopts
Amendment
0610 H and I now move ought to pass as
amended and rep uh recognize
representative licki I second that
motion moved and seconded that we adopt
the motion of ought to pass as amended
discussion seeing none as soon as you're
ready Mr clerk I ask you to call the
role on the question of ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 1644
FN Vice chair Thomas yes representative
nder yes representative Harrington yes
representative Wicky yes representative
Bry yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Campell yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
MC Williams yes representative cran yes
representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan yes representative
muns yes representative Noel yes
representative Thomas no representative
Corman yes representative rolds yes
chairman Vose yes
191 by a vote of 19 to1 the committee
adopts the recommendation of ought to
pass as amended on House Bill
1644 as amended by amendment number
I will write the committee report will
there be a Minority Report there will
not
okay would there be any objection to
calendar hearing no objections this bill
consent with the amendment the FN is
consent okay with that I'm going to
close the executive session on House
Bill 1644
FN now before we open an exec session on
House Bill
1431 we need to have a brief
discussion about where the amendment
that we're going to adopt might be do
you know representative
Kaplan okay so we're going to take a
break while we wait for the office of
legislation legislative services to
produce a new
version of an amendment that we think we
will all like for House Bill
1431 this new
Amendment takes the amendment that I
propose during our work session and adds
natural gas to
it
and retains the original Amendment the
rest of the original amendment I think
that's acceptable to all parties so as
soon as we get that new Amendment we
will look at it we'll discuss it and
then we'll decide how to deal with it so
until that time can we take a
representative Harrington yeah when you
say say add natural gas is it going to
add natural gas as it was in the the
last there was one amendment that had
natural gas in it already is that the
one that section of that Amendment okay
right yes I assume that's how what it
will look like I haven't seen the
amendment but um representative Kaplan
OSS okay let's take a five minute break
while house committee services and
prints up the amendment and then we'll
come back let's say at uh 1:30 and take
up this amendment before we go
representative Bernardi has a question
while we're in this break I want to take
a poll of who can go to ISO New England
on 15
March I can okay I I I'm just going to
call a roll you say yay or nay all right
chairman
Vose no uh oh then we're not going Vice
chairman Thomas yes representative naer
yes representative Harrington no
representative Lui tentatively
yes representative
Bry yes bernardy yes uh representative
PL representative of summer is not here
representative Kennedy
no representative McGee no I already I
have an appointment that day so I can't
do it representative MC Williams no I
have to work representative crean
probably
not representative parall most likely
yes uh representative Kaplan yeah I can
make it representative Ms
no representative Noel yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Corman no I can't make it that day
representative
rolds I tentatively
yes okay three four five 6 7 8 9 10 11
we have we have 11 including the
tentatives thank
you okay please return to your seats by
you
okay everybody uh I said we'd re begin
at restart at 1:30 unfortunately we're
not going to be able to restart restart
at 1:30 but I want to tell you
why so representative Kaplan asked OS to
draft a new Amendment and they did and
he got it just before we recessed a few
minutes ago or broke uh took a break a
few minutes ago and he was looking at it
and he discovered in the gas section
they forgot to remove the line about
environmental stuff so he went back and
asked for yet another new
version and so that version is in the
works and so we will have to wait until
that one comes through before we can um
before we can vote on this bill so
that's where we are so I'd ask you all
to stay close to your seats and
representative Kaplan will let us know
the minute this new Amendment arrives
and uh we will go from there yeah Chris
bringing it down as soon as it's ready
so Christy will bring it down as soon as
it's ready okay Mr chair duck out yes
representative Thomas I'm presenting a
bill at 2 o'cl just for your information
not here
obviously okay so um I have a time limit
appreciate that you can use the time
productively to write your Minority
Report for I just did thanks to
excellent representative MC Williams
okay please take your seats everyone we
can now complete complete our work
activity for the
day we now have a new Amendment for
House Bill
1431 is everyone
here it appears that we are so the chair
recognizes representative Kaplan for a
motion yeah I move a to pass on
Amendment 2024
0663 chair recognizes representative
Kennedy second moved and seconded that
we adopt Amendment
d663 to House Bill
1431 chair recognizes Mr chair
representative Kap discuss the amendment
we don't have it yeah we don't have it
to that was my fault I apologize I
forgot to hand it to representative
Bernard we want to go fast but not too
fast so representative Kaplan has uh the
text of the amendment it's working its
way around why don't you describe what
it
does okay thank you Mr chair this
amendment basically amends the original
bill by getting us back to the original
language of an assessment of it keeps
378 37 the the definition of energy
policy and the sort of the principle the
first principle of what uh integrated
planning should be all
about takes us back to the original
language on assessment of distribution
infrastructure
only and uh states that the the
assessments of any assessment of a
plan's integration cons has to be
consistent with the state energy
strategy uh and then it goes on to add
some language around Gas Distribution
Gas Utilities as well so that the Gas
Utilities are also included in the need
plans so I think this
amendment gets the Public Utilities
Commission back to its it gives it a
tool to get back to its oversight Duty
over our state's
utilities and it also has the uh the the
virtue of Simplicity and
uh and uh you know efficiency so that we
you don't get bogged down in these
proceedings so I think it meets uh I
think it meets our
needs thank you representative Kaplan as
I read the amendment it does exactly
what representative
Kaplan uh suggested that it would do it
takes an earlier
Amendment and adds gas to it and that's
it and so um I think this amendment
passes muster and I think we uh should
seriously consider passing it were there
copies could Mr Lata oh he has one okay
I just wanted to make sure he had one
there are some extra copies here if
anybody
needs couple of extra copies here if
anybody would
like to uh to peruse this amendment okay
amendment representative
thank you Mr chair um I still have one
reservation here there was something in
uh Amendment one that we were looking at
before 0609 H
about that uh no distribution rate
change would be approved or ordered
until a plan had been approved and
that's no longer here and I'm just
concerned that there's really no teeth
in this that the timing repeats until a
plan is approved but there's there's
nothing about all right well until you
approve a plan you you don't get to
change your distribution rates so I'm
just a little concerned about
that so during the public hearing it was
that issue was addressed by I think it
was Mr France of the Department of
energy and he stated
that you could run seriously into a
constitutional issue there of depriving
the ability the utility of the ability
to recover its costs prudently and so he
suggested that no enforcement me
mechanism was really necessary for this
bill and so that's why my original
Amendment took it out and why
representative Kaplan agreed that that
that was a suitable change if I could
just add a comment on that I I think the
fact that the utilities are on board
with this process says a lot uh and if
if that's the case and they're carrying
out these plans in in a you know sort of
good faith effort that that is good
enough for
discussion seeing none looks like we can
ask the clerk to call the role on the
question of the adoption of the
amendment Amendment 0663
h was there a motion on that
yes all done representative K move the
adoption of the amendment and
representative Kennedy seconded the
motion good thank
you Mr clerk please call the role on the
adoption of the amendment Vice chair
Thomas yes representative naer yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Wiki yes representative
brne yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes repres
representative camell yes representative
Kennedy yes representative
McGee yes representative McWilliams yes
representative crean yes representative
parshall yes representative Kaplan yes
representative muns yes representative
well yes representative Thomas yes
representative Corman yes representative
rolds yes chairman Vos yes 20 Z by a
vote of 20 to nothing the committee
0663 for House Bill
representative Kaplan for a
motion I move that uh we
adopt hb1
1431 as
amended recognizes representative chair
recognizes representative Kennedy I
second moved and second that we adopt
the motion of ought to pass as amended
on House Bill
needed seeing none Mr clerk please call
the role on the question of ought to
passes amended Vice chair Thomas yes
representative naer yes representative
Harrington yes representative Wicky yes
representative Bry yes represent
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative camell yes representative
Kennedy yes representative McGee yes
representative
McWilliams yes representative crean yes
representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan yes representative
muns yes representative Noel yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Corman yes representative rold
yes chairman Vose yes 20 Zero by a vote
of 20 to nothing the motion of ought to
pass as amended is adopted by the
committee without objection we'll put
calendar no objection representative
report I wasn't expecting you to object
[Laughter]
although maybe you will object to
writing the committee report but you're
on the hook
nevertheless and you have to write it
before you leave this afternoon
so check in with
Rebecca so with that I'm going to close
1431 and that really concludes our
business for the day so I will remind
everyone that we will meet again weather
permitting next Tuesday which is
February
20th at 10:00 a.m. for a full committee
work session on the last three bills
that we have before us for this session
and then at 1:00 that afternoon we'll
have an exec session on those same three
bills and I will attempt to send out
amendments for those bills if needed by
this Friday if possible representative n
um just clarification did you they you
said 10:00 a.m. but did you mean 9:00
a.m. no I meant 10:00 a.m.
okay unless there's an objection does
does anybody want to start at
nine I thought 10 would be a better
start time especially since every other
Tuesday this room is used from 9: to 10
by another group y so I thought it'd be
safe to start at
10: anything else El see you all next
Tuesday have a wonderful rest of the
week and a nice weekend and Happy
you